If we talk about twins then there are two types of
twins, mono zygote and die zygote. What
mono zygote means is that your human
body is human female, it
released only one ovum and it got fertilized by one sperm.
After
fertilization, which is your liver, it is
divided and what has it done, it has formed two
mangoes, then here your
twins will be similar to you,
their gender will also be the same, their age and
features will also be the same.
If you talk about die zygote then
what does die zygote mean that the human being
is female, she produced two ovum and these were
fertilized by two different sperms.
What will happen with this, you can basically become two different genders.
And their features may also be
dissimilar to yours.